I am left with reasontv we are at the
republican national convention in
Cleveland we're at progressive field
where the Indians occasionally play
baseball we're talking with Rory Cooper
is a senior adviser to the nevertrump
super PAC and we're asking him what
happens now that never Trump is you know
kind of done right he's the he's the
candidate right well he's the nominee
and it's something that Republicans are
going to have to reckon with what we're
going to start looking to do is to see
what the conservative movement and the
Republican Party looks like post
November it's my belief the Donald Trump
cannot win in November and argue you
want him to lose well I don't think that
him being president would be good for
this country I certainly also don't
think the Hillary Clinton would be a
good president but if you aside from my
personal beliefs you just look at the
numbers you know Republican parties have
carried certain demographic since Harry
Truman and Donald Trump straining I'm
upside down what is the essential never
Trump case that motivated this movement
well I mean for me it's probably America
primarily a character issue I believe
that one of the most important
characteristics and a political leader
that I saw in george bush and then i saw
an eric cantor and i'd like to see in
people that i support is humility it's
it's an underrated characteristic and
Donald Trump is on the opposite end of
the spectrum on that you need somebody
who understands that the that the office
that they're seeking is bigger than them
that it's that there's something to
protect their and that was step one step
two is listen I've got a six year old a
three year old and a one year old and I
started off watching conventions and
Sunday morning shows with my dad and
getting interested in politics I can't
let them in the room and he's on TV cuz
I'm unsure of what he's going to say or
what lessons I'm gonna have to counter
program about not bullying about not
saying things about people because
they're different than you Trump is not
the cause of a Republican Party crack-up
really he's the effect and whether it's
the Bush administration you know Bush
overall increase spending about fifty
percent real dollars over over his time
in office the wars were not popular
he was compassionate conservative isn't
but he grew the the size scope and
spending of government and it doesn't
seem like the Republican Party ever
really kind of grappled with that I mean
is Trump to cause her to see the effect
of what's going on here yeah I would
somewhat disagree with the premise I
mean the the Republican Party has
problems that need to be fixed for sure
and some of it does go to what you
alluded to and a lot of that exists
between so-called establishment
Republicans and conservative Republicans
in fact you've seen those people
actually united against Trump in this
case I think you know historians will be
spending decades trying to figure out
where trunk how Trump got to where he is
my personal belief is i think that the
anxieties are real that Americans are
facing they think that their jobs and
their wages aren't good enough they
believe that there is a security threat
they believe that there's an immigration
problem some of those things you don't
buy anything I've no i buy i buy the
knee that when you buy that the concerns
are there but is there is there an
immigration problem in America of course
that we have to secure the border right
now and I think that most Republicans
you know Donald Trump acts like he it
was the first to bring up this issue in
fact Republicans and debating how to fix
immigration for the last five ten years
i believe that all Republicans are going
to have to figure out not to dismiss the
Trump voter but how to speak to the
anxieties in a more constructive way
Trump is doing poorly among young people
actually Hillary Clinton is also doing
relatively poor poorly among young
people is somebody like Gary Johnson the
libertarian who is doing pretty well in
the polls is he somebody that never
Trumper's can actually see themselves
voting for certainly I think that a lot
of people are looking at Gary Johnson
seriously as the person at the low for I
think that Gary Johnson has an
opportunity here that so far I believe
has been missed in ada Lee in putting
himself out there as the real
alternative disease too i mean honestly
I've never seen election cycle where
there is a better opportunity for a
third party candidate to jump in there
and be that I think that young people
certainly Donald Trump's numbers are
absolutely important with people under
30 trying to make sure those folks don't
gravitate towards Hillary but also I
believe that they are missing an
opportunity right now social
conservatives who oppose Donald Trump
you're saying libertarians are missing
an opportunity with social conservative
talk a little bit about that because
there's definitely a real golf there yet
so I you know I understand that the
Libertarian Party has issues that are
not in alignment with all social
conservatives I think that this is an
opportunity for them to say we
understand that you disagree with us on
a few of these issues and for some of
you there's a single most important
issue but this election has taken a new
meaning and we believe that we can come
to a date on on certain issues in order
to protect the greater economic and
national security well-being of this
country and frankly national security
being another issue we're finding some
middle ground might actually help Gary
Johnson bill well find a greater amount
of support and then finally I think that
they need to look at this from a
perspective of actually winning an
election and not just being on a debate
stage when they talk about moral
victories of or when other their
supporters talk about it's a victory
just getting on the stage the victory of
the party if you want to be taken
seriously in presidential elections you
have to take yourself seriously and that
starts by treating the election like you
can win it final question what is the
worst outcome of a trump presidency I
realized you don't think he's going to
win I think you're right about that but
you know what is the absolute worst case
scenario other other than that he gets
reelected in 2020 I believe in my core
that the entire world looks the United
States for political moral leadership
and if they believe that the United
States is not strong is not willing to
stand up for them and I want to stand up
for its principles that that are we face
global insecurity and an economic
standpoint from a national security
standpoint I believe that the world
needs to believe that the United States
is in a good place and right now for the
last seven years I think that that
reputation has eroded the Democrats
would argue that it eroded the eight
years previous to that and maybe even
some libertarians I think that most
Americans wake up look at the news and
think that the world's falling apart and
it's not going to get better if Donald
Trump as the president frankly it's it's
not it might not get better if Hillary
Clinton's the president but so it's
going to take a strong Republican
Congress screaming require libertarians
Republicans working together
to make sure that we at least have a
strong firewall against against liberal
or trumpism liberalism or trumpism
whatever it is that threatens the
security of our country and of the globe
we will leave it there thanks so much
we've been talking with Rory Cooper is
the senior advisor to the nevertrump
super PAC thanks for talking to us
you